movimientos que recuerdan a la guerra
fría rusia aprobó este jueves un misil
supersónico contra un objetivo ubicado
en las aguas del mar blanco un
lanzamiento que coincide con el del
mensaje del presidente vladimir putin a
occidente no es nuevo esto los socios
occidentales empeoran la situación
entregando aquí armas letales modernas y
realizando ejercicios de provocación en
el mar negro donde su mayor coste no
buscas los tramos nuestras
preocupaciones en este sentido hablamos
de líneas rojas pero nuestros socios son
peculiares y atienden nuestras
advertencias de manera superficial y
modesto
la tensión crece
putin acusa a la otan de acabar con los
mecanismos de diálogo un mes después de
la ruptura entre el país y la alianza
mientras calificó de insatisfactorias
las relaciones con eeuu
relaciones complejas por el conflicto
entre rusia y ucrania kiev está
desplegando militares cerca de la
frontera con crime a territorio
ucraniano que rusia anexionó en 2014
mientras recibe apoyo de sus aliados
occidentales
porque buscamos el apoyo político de los
euros socios atlánticos aumentamos la
presión diplomática y las sanciones y
llegamos a acuerdos para el suministro
de armas de defensa adicionales para
nuestro ejército este miércoles rusia
publicó documentos diplomáticos
oficiales una respuesta a alemania y
francia- que le acusaron de socavar el
proceso de negociación a cuatro bandas
con ucrania conocido como normandía
con un intento de poner fin al conflicto
iniciado cuando los separatistas rusos
se levantaron en armas en las regiones
de donets y lugares